one of the mayan kings is sitting in
some sort of a device and they start
looking at it
he's controlling something with his feet
he's got his hands on something and he's
got his mouth on something
and eric von daniken was the first guy
to come out and say that is a
he's in some sort of a craft or some
sort of a ship he's flying it
he went to egypt he went to south
america he went to peru
and he started finding the same thing at
each of these locations and during this
period of time there was no
communication between these people
still trying to understand how did the
south americans
right know to do pyramids yeah how did
they do this in
egypt how did they do this in china
there's
pyramids now they're finding in china
they just found more pyramids in
antarctica
there's now they're saying there's
pyramids in bosnia
so he has literally the awakening uh
is been something that has been
obviously a long time happening
but now people are really starting to
see what he was talking about so now
you look at peru and they had these um
large faces with these big eyes
and you couldn't see these drawings
unless you were in the sky
so they go to easter island
and in a cave underground and again now
i'm currently curious is how these guys
even had light under there to do this
they carved those same faces into the
stone easter island was just that it was
an island it was 4 000 miles from any
land mass
of course these people are all extinct
now they actually made these big heads
and had them all surrounded
on on itself but they didn't
until the communication got what it is
today we didn't know that these all
these things were the same
and now that they can start to travel
and start to see hey this was the same
as here they're just calling it
something different if you look at some
of the
the um the very very intricate
uh carvings that were done these were
concrete carvings obviously
and everybody was carrying a purse and
he started noticing that this purse
seemed to be
universal with the egyptians with the
with the
the mayans with all these different
groups
and he started talking to a nasa
astronaut one day and the nasa astronaut
pulled up a picture and all the
astronauts
carry this life support system with them
that's actually hooked up to their
system as they're getting onto the
to the rocket so he's like what if
they the people at that time were
witnessing these guys carrying some sort
of a
life support system with them but didn't
know how to didn't know what it was so
it just
shows up as a purse on all these
different
drawings that's so cool so it is it's
amazing when you really start to think
about the bigger picture of it because
how could um peru
know what south america was doing how
could south america know what the
egyptians were doing
right so it just became one of these
things that where
nobody really seemed to do that so eric
von daniken
started to do that he started to show
everybody hey wait a minute
how could they possibly know this was
this just a lucky guess
did they know that um the
pyramid or he went to i think one of the
first places he ended up going was
india and india had
uh what do they call it they actually
had a name for them but they look like
they were pyramids but they look like
these
flying craft called
what were these things called here hang
on a second let me look it up real quick
aidan go through your pictures this is
probably in there uh it is i put it in
there oh man it's right here
uh they're called arunka vamanas
okay and they were actually flying
vehicles and if you look at the
towers aidan it's this one right here
yeah if you look at the towers they
built
it's that one through india dude these
towers
are amazing they are so intricate there
is so much going on with these actual
towers
that you're like well did were guys in
there with chisels come on man you would
break off the hand there'd be no way you
could do some of the very small
intricate work that's required to do so
he
started looking at hey how are they
doing this what's causing this and india
even today i think i'm gonna put that on
my bucket list because it's definitely
one of the most amazing places on the
planet to go see
that makes you scratch your head and go
how could somebody do such intricate
artwork and it's
hundreds and thousands years old so he
started to really look at that so then
from there he went to egypt
and started to talk to egyptologists now
egyptologists
still don't have a view that this has
anything to do with aliens they still
believe it was all
uh based on humankind then there's two
beliefs on this in this world you've got
the scientific side that says hey we
started from apes and we kind of came
down the road
and you have a religious side that says
no you know jesus and god did all this
and made us who we are today
whichever way you believe we we end up
coming at the end we're the greatest
thing on the planet
so and yet there's got to be more to
this
in the bigger picture than what's really
going on we wouldn't have all this
um information floating around today
that so
i mean look at the guys that initially
went with dr greer
they went to dc they did project
disclosure
they brought in 40 military personnel
they were all verified as who they were
now dr greer is a doctor he's an
emergency room doctor
oh there they are there's the okay what
explain what these are now the center
one the ramana is that as big as you can
get it aiden
that is that is the actual craft they
said they flew around in
oh oh now the towers on either side are
these are structures that are in
india today these are religious uh
towers and
what is that that goes through the
center of them in the middle one or the
other
and the middle one on each side there's
like two things that go up oh yeah you
know what i'm not sure they showed they
were trying to show some sort of
anti-gravity material that would
actually let that thing take off and
land
but they talk about these things flying
around in their religion and actually
having
fights in the air shooting each other
down
so of course what did the indians do
they designed the buildings to look
just like that flying craft did
so i mean is that an accident and if you
look at the detail i mean these things
are
huge monstrous and where are these at
these are in india
india i mean just just amazing so that's
where
from this is really where eric von
danigan really started to put together
this whole idea that the gods were
really
uh astronauts and so he said it's one of
the best places in the world to go
because
so much of what they created is still
there now do you think that
like potential alien sightings back then
in those times in the times of like the
mayans or the times of the ancient
egyptians
do you think that aliens maybe weren't
as sophisticated as they were
like in the 90s or in the 80s
because my question is because they have
those those packs on them right those
bags that you say would be like life
support
right but then you hear like stories of
like the zimbabwe encounter
where there was just these aliens
wearing black suits and they were just
skin-tight black suits that's all they
had
and they were standing there just
telepathically communicating with them
and i've actually heard that a couple
times believe it or not nasa has those
same
uh suits now they're getting rid of all
the big heavy spacesuits they've gone to
a skin-like suit
that's over your body that almost would
you like i'm wondering if over the time
if we've been visited by different
species of aliens well listen eric von
daniken said
to know no avail that when the
um the uh shoot i'm gonna think of this
group now
one of the groups that were coming here
uh they were really kind of like fallen
angels
and they were told hey the while you're
here let them
let these people do their work there's
no having any sex with them and they
actually
came down and ended up having sex with
us so they believe through gene
manipulation
and through these things actually
spawning us this is how we all kind of
came to be and they believe this
happened over about 50
000 years so there's this millions of
years we hear about you know hey you
were an ape
i don't i never kind of bought off on
that to begin with i mean you're an ape
i said
why aren't we still changing why aren't
we still evolving um i mean i would
think if
it happened then it would still be
happening today i don't see monkeys
getting a whole lot smarter elephants
aren't talking
yeah you know so where would that at
what point does it stop
and also why the monkey why not the
elephant yeah well you know listen if
you
really look if you go back and look at
the um uh the gentleman who's the one
who came up with this whole concept
i mean i'm cracking up his name flips my
mind darwin
darwin thank you very much he went to
the
galapagos looked at the islands here he
only spent
two weeks and then came up with this
idea that this is what happens and he
did this through birds that were there
because birds had
the same bird that was on a different
island had a curved beak so that he
could reach inside these
cactuses and pull out the seeds but it
was the same bird on the other island
had a straight beak
so he started to believe that through
your environment
that's what actually changed us but
again he spent two weeks there and all
of a sudden that is law
that's we all hear that now we all came
this is how we grew up it was
you know chimpanzees and then we were
walking and then all of a sudden now
we're smart
and so he he started to look at that and
say now that that can't be
that it just can't it would still be
happening today yeah animals would be
still
changing that we we would see in the
last ten thousand years that something
has happened to these animals because
we're not seeing that
he goes so but if you go back and you
start looking at when these guys started
talking about gods or
there was even pictures and i meant to
get some of these as well if you look at
the 14th and 15th century
these pictures that were actually
painted and there's something up in the
sky
in the back behind it you know whether
it's the virgin mary and some guy's
pointing at it and his dogs looking at
it
so these things have been going on for
so long that people
didn't really know what to call them and
then listen even through the 70s and 80s
here
people were kind of you're kind of a
clown or a nutcase
if you believed in this stuff um
you